following the release of the highly
intriguing breath of the wild sequel
trailer analysis after analysis and
Theory after Theory have been created
and uploaded by several Zelda theorists
and even those who would normally cover
other game titles it's no question that
this new trailer has the gaming world
captivated and has revealed just enough
information about link Zelda Ganondorf
and others to keep us all wondering some
of the theories that have become much
more popular recently are theories
surrounding the mysterious zone AI tribe
which is an ancient tribe of barbarians
that lived long ago in the fair on
region said to have served the dragon of
the spring of courage who we can safely
assume is Faraj the green dragon still
alive today
this ancient forgotten tribe has one
thing in common with someone we know
very well the zone I serve or represent
the spirit of courage just like the hero
better known to us as link is known to
represent as well could it be that link
bears more than a spiritual resemblance
to the mysterious zone I people of the
distant past could it be that link is a
descendant of the zone I tribe what's up
guys masks antennae banded here and
today we're gonna delve headfirst into
zone I theory which like I already
mentioned is pretty popular these days
so chances are if you're watching this
you've already given the zone I tried
some serious thought and or spend some
time already watching theories covering
the ancient people group on that note
I'm not really going to spend too much
time going over theory about who they
are or what their purpose was there are
already a bunch of theories out there
covering this if you haven't seen any
just yet I highly recommend the recent
zone a video uploaded by the
Commonwealth realm called Ganondorf and
the zone I mystery featuring Nintendo
black crisis they cover some good stuff
and make some great points that I
basically completely agree with that
being said we are going to go forward
with VIN Zelda lore piecing together
what could prove that link is a
descendant of the zone I people real
quick before we get into the video I
like to remind people that this voice
you're listening to right now yeah you
know me I'm a real person not only am i
extensively
liking this video and subscribing to
stick around for much more Zelda content
to come if you do that not only will you
be informed of all my new content coming
out but you'll be able to check out
everything else I've done already and
YouTube will continue to recommend this
content to other Zelda fans just like
you and me feel free to leave me a
comment below if you enjoyed this
content as well or if you want to point
out something I may have missed now
without further ado on to the content
starting out we're gonna quickly cover
what is believed to be the zone I tribes
purpose and legacy according to the
video I referenced earlier from the
Commonwealth realm the zone I were
basically an old advisory to the kingdom
of Hyrule on Ganon and how to defeat him
now
where I don't really agree with their
theory is the part where they state that
the hylians under decree of the Hylian
King basically exterminated the zone I
do too well divide and conquer I suppose
I think there's a different reasoning
behind the disappearance of the old
barbarian tribe but to explain what
exactly I'm on about I need to jump out
of breath with a wild for a second and
talk about another faction related
closely to the legendary hero have you
ever heard of the Knights of Hyrule aka
the Hylian Knights I'm not talking about
soldiers or other sorts of footmen that
may employ the armies of Hyrule but
rather the more powerful protectors of
Hylian Realty referred to canonically as
Hylian Knights historically speaking
Knights were oftentimes members of
royalty themselves and were always more
of a threat on the battlefield due to
greater quality weapons armor training
and nutrition they were able to obtain
due to their rich royal heritage in
zelda lore the Hylian Knights share a
similar background in that they are all
descendants of the legendary hero proven
in the Hyrule historia book page 93 now
if you're interested in Hylian knights
and whether or not they are royalty and
whether or not that by extension means
link is royalty home I just so happened
to do a video on that exact subject if
you're at all interested in this theory
I'll have a link to the other video in
the description below or at the end of
this video or both so please feel free
to check it out after we're done here
anyway link is normally a descendant of
Knightly blood as we see in the game a
Link to the Past when it's revealed his
uncle is a knight and by
tenshun link himself skipping back to
breath of the wild
to quote zelda here link is absolutely
the son of a knight of hyrule zelda
states he quote dedicated himself to
becoming a knight as well just like his
father with links heritage and being a
knight explained let's go back to
talking about the zone i some of you out
there who have been paying really close
attention to what i'm saying this whole
time have probably got a decent idea
about where I'm going with this by now
what if the zone I tribe were not
exterminated but rather affiliated as
Knights I mean we already have a tribe
dedicated in Zelda lore to serving the
dragon Faraj who obviously represents
the goddess furore and by extension her
spirit of courage would it really be so
far of a stretch to say that the zone I
tribe were also descendants of the
legendary hero and that if they were
descendants of the hero that is why they
inherited the blessings of the spirit of
courage if they like the Commonwealth
realm touchtone served the goddesses and
helped Hyrule defend against the forces
of ganon and have been known to be great
warriors
why wouldn't they continue on to join
Hyrule as Knights that defend Hylian
royalty against Ganon one might say to
this point that the zone I tribe could
not have become the Knights of Hyrule
because they exist in breath of the wild
at the current standpoint in the
timeline whereas the Knights of Hyrule
have been confirmed to have existed as
far in the past as ocarina of time
chronologically speaking this may be a
fair point at first glance but and this
is already something a lot of Zelda fans
theorized about what if the 10,000 year
gap talked about in breadth of the wild
actually encapsulate the entire Zelda
franchise or even just most of it if the
zone I tribe existed 10,000 years ago
and that was before ocarina of time it
could be that they went on to join the
kingdom of Hyrule as Hylian Knights
which could be seen as the next step in
their purpose of worshiping the spirit
of courage and defending Hylian royalty
follow this train of logic and
eventually you find yourself at link the
hero of wilds haile a knight and zone I
warrior could this explain the strange
reaction we see in the trailer when the
mysterious hand clutching ganondorf's
chest seemingly transports itself to
link if that hand is O&I magic what if
link is able to
caPSURE its power because he is a
descendant of the zone I admittedly
there isn't too much evidence within
breath the wild that links the zone I
and the Knights or even the zone I and
Link for that matter but there is one
thing that may help my argument although
it is a minor point you know how link
has for the first time in any Zelda game
the ability to change what armor he's
wearing at will well all the armor he
can find in-game has one thing in common
amongst themselves they all fit link
this may seem silly but it is true that
link fits into both highly and Knight
armor and ancient barbarian armor sure
link may not be fully grown and it's
also not too far of a stretch to say
that the barbarian armor may actually be
one size fits all I mean just look at it
but if you think about it what are the
odds that an ancient suit of armor
crafted meticulously by warriors for
warriors would fit this highly and
Knight thousands of years later I mean
unless genetically linked has the zone
AI stature in his bloodline and that's
why he fits perfectly but what do you
all think let me know in the comments
below I want to thank you all for
watching so much please be sure to LIKE
and subscribe if you enjoyed this
content and want to see more also here
is a huge thank you to my new patreon
supporters Andrew closed Callie and
Skylar Hughes you guys are amazing and a
huge encouragement to me if anyone
watching is interested in supporting
Maskman and abandoned or just seeing
what the tier rewards are I'll have the
link to my patreon page in the
description below chat with me and my
subscribers on discord which I'll also
link in the description check out the
other videos I've done on breath of the
wild to keep the hype real guys this is
Mastana bandits signing out peace
[Music]